Prof: For the last three
weeks,
then, we've been going through
some of the major developments
in terms of political and
religious change in the course
of the sixteenth century,
and for the next three weeks
we'll be looking at other
aspects of what was going on in
the reign of Elizabeth and under
the early Stuarts,
dealing with a number of themes
that run across from about 1560
to 1640 and then we'll return to
the political narrative.
So I'm going to look at things
like witchcraft and crime and
popular protest and education
and the growth of literacy.
But first of all this week,
in order to understand all of
these developments and create
the context of change,
we need to know what was going
on in economy and society,
both of which were changing in
their structure quite
significantly in these two
generations at the turn of the
sixteenth and seventeenth
centuries.
And today I'll focus on the
economic developments.
So, a bit of economic history.
Economic history is rarely
immensely popular but it does
matter.
It's absolutely basic.
It's perhaps an unfamiliar kind
of history.
It's mostly done in economics
departments,
but what I'll try to do
basically is to give you a clear
overview of what we know about
what seems to have been
happening in this period and
your handout will provide you
with some statistics to chart
the overall developments and
illustrate some of the details.
Okay.
So by the 1560s already,
as you know,
population growth and price
inflation had impacted to some
degree upon established patterns
of social relationships
especially on the land between
landlords and tenants.
In this situation there was
need for sustained economic
expansion if a growing
population was to be maintained
and in particular if the younger
generation were to be able to
find employment,
to enjoy living standards
comparable to those of their
parents,
and such expansion needed to be
considerable if it was to keep
pace with continued population
rise.
If you look at your handout,
table number one there,
we have the best figures
available for population showing
that by the beginning of
Elizabeth's reign in 1561 it had
already reached about three
million,
by 1601 it had topped four
and by 1641 the population had
risen to just over five million.
In fact, the population in
England seems to have been
rising faster and for rather
longer than was generally the
case in Europe at the time.
Between the 1520s and the
1640s, the population of England
and Wales roughly doubled
whereas in most European
countries which--
continental European
countries--which have been
studied the rise was something
like 50%.
That suggests that whatever the
population rise in England had
in common with what was going on
elsewhere in Europe,
perhaps in terms of its
origins, it was nonetheless
being sustained rather longer,
perhaps because of factors
peculiar to the English
situation.
There seems to have been a
capacity to absorb increased
numbers of people to a somewhat
greater extent than in much of
continental Europe.
And that this could happen at
all is of course an indication
that some kind of economic
expansion was probably going on.
And so the question arises and
has been extensively
investigated as to what were the
areas of economic expansion in
this period.
Well, in a predominantly rural
society, of course,
we need to begin with
agriculture.
And if you look at table two on
your handout,
2(a), there's an index there of
agricultural output.
It's the best estimate
currently available,
calculated by the agricultural
historian Mark Overton,
and it suggests that grain
output rose by about 38% in
England between 1550 and 1600
and by a further 26% between
1600 and 1650.
Over the entire period
something like a 75% increase in
grain output.
Well, how did they achieve that?
One thing they did was to
extend the cultivated area.
In fact, very little land was
not used at all so really this
was largely a matter of changing
the use of the land so as to
increase the intensity of its
use.
They did that in many ways.
One way was by clearing
woodlands and bringing the
woodland into arable production.
A good deal of that went on in
the heavily wooded areas of the
West Midlands here,
and elsewhere piecemeal.
Another thing they did was to
drain waterlogged land and to
reclaim it for agriculture.
There was a good deal of that
going on piecemeal around the
country.
Down here in eastern England
for example a lot of salt marsh
along the coast was brought in
permanently.
They built dikes so that it
wouldn't flood and drained it,
much in the manner that was
practiced in the Netherlands,
of course, and brought that
land into permanent pasture use.
A lot of wasteland was plowed
up and brought into cultivation.
There was a lot of piecemeal
change of that kind wherever
wasteland was available,
but there were also some very
large projects of that kind
which were sponsored and
overseen by the royal privy
council.
In the west of England a lot of
forested land was
'disafforested' by the crown;
that is its status as forest
land was canceled.
Woodlands were cleared.
Land was brought into
cultivation all over the west.
Another major scheme was in the
fenlands of East Anglia.
The fens were from the 1620s
onwards gradually drained and
that land was brought into
cultivation.
Dutch engineers were brought in
because of their expertise in
draining land,
building dikes,
drainage channels and so forth.
It's because of that drainage
which took place in the
seventeenth century that if you
drive through that area you'll
find the roads are higher than
the surrounding land.
Well, much change then of this
kind going on,
and this tended to recast the
balance between arable and
pastoral production in the
kingdom as a whole.
It also furthered increased
specialization in accordance
with the best use of the land.
In the forest of Arden,
for example,
in Warwickshire an area which
was previously largely an area
of grazing in forest clearances
much of the forest was cleared
and the land went over from meat
production to arable and
dairying.
Amongst the arable crops they
began growing more barley as
well as wheat to diversify the
product.
They generally increased the
food base of the area.
They were producing milk and
cheese and grain as well as
meat, and you get other areas
where there's even more
diversification.
Down in Kent to the southeast
of London.
Northern Kent became an area
specializing in producing wheat
for the bakers of London.
Other areas of the county
specialized in fattening cattle
which were driven down from the
north, fattened up and then went
to butchers in London.
There were areas specializing
in hop production,
as there still are,
for the brewers of London;
areas specializing in market
gardening for the city.
Proximity to the vast food
market of London,
of course, encouraged
specialization of that kind.
And such specialization in
various parts of the kingdom in
turn encouraged intensification
of cultivation.
Sometimes that was by
introducing technical changes in
agricultural production.
There was a lot of attention
paid to better forms of manuring
the land,
not just using animal muck but
also spreading lime on the
fields or 'marling' the fields.
Marl is a kind of chalky clay.
They would dig it up and spread
it on the fields and then plow
it in.
Techniques of that kind had the
effect of reducing the acidity
of the soil and they encouraged
nitrogen mineralization which
encouraged the fertility of the
soil.
They didn't know the chemistry
of what was happening,
but they knew that it worked
and techniques of this kind were
quite widely practiced.
There were also technical
changes in the form of changing
rotations in the use of land
between having it down to grass
or plowing it up for arable
crops,
in particular an innovation
which is known as convertible
husbandry,
or up and down husbandry,
it was often called.
Previously, the practice had
been in the great open fields
around villages to leave one of
them fallow each year.
It would be rested for a single
year and then brought back into
production.
Convertible husbandry was a
much more efficient form of
rotation.
You would leave the grass--the
land down to grass for quite a
long time,
ten years, twelve years
perhaps, then plow it up for
just two or three years and then
put it down to grass again.
The effect of this change in
rotation was that the land
was--got its heart restored
better.
You got greatly improved cereal
yields when it was plowed up for
arable,
but at the same time you had
more of your acreage down to
grass at any one time,
so you could keep more animals.
So they could increase both
their output of grain and the
density of the livestock which
they raised.
This practice,
up and down or convertible
husbandry,
had long been known in some
areas but it gradually spread as
a particularly efficient
practice,
and it spreads all over lowland
England between about the 1580s
and the 1650s.
And finally,
change of all these kinds could
be facilitated by enclosing the
land into individually managed
farms.
As you know,
in the sixteenth century
there'd been great hostility to
enclosure for pasture which took
land out of arable production.
In the late sixteenth century,
partly because of this
hostility to enclosure,
the enclosure movement
slackened, but at the turn of
the seventeenth century it began
to pick up again.
In the central England county
of Leicestershire in the--
what people refer to as the
Midland Plain of central
England,
for example,
about a third of the county had
already been enclosed by 1550.
In the second half of the
sixteenth century,
only 5% more was enclosed.
The movement slackened.
But in the early seventeenth
century it picked up again and
40% more of the county was
enclosed.
Similar figures have been
produced for other areas
particularly in the Midlands.
Well, this second wave of
enclosure,
of dividing up the fields and
common into smaller fields
individually managed,
it was different in two
respects from the earlier
enclosure movement.
First of all,
it was now not so much
enclosure for conversion to
pasture, especially conversion
to sheep ranching.
Now it tended to be enclosure
for the practice of improved
arable husbandry or convertible
husbandry.
When the forests of the west
were cleared and the fens of the
east were drained,
the land brought into
production tended to be divided
up into individual fields and
then let out to local farmers
where they practiced convertible
husbandry in their enclosed
farms.
Secondly, this differed because
it was not a thing which was
just pushed through unilaterally
by the local gentry who wanted
to create sheep ranches in the
early sixteenth century.
Now it was a movement which
tended to proceed by agreement--
agreements which would be
struck between local gentlemen
and the principal local farmers,
their biggest tenants in the
main.
And so you find all over the
kingdom local communities coming
to agreements of this kind to
enclose the common fields or the
common pastures.
To take just one example,
there's a village up in the
West Midlands called Highley,
which has been much studied,
and it has excellent records,
and at Highley,
for example,
it was in the 1610s and the
1620s that the open fields of
the parish were gradually
enclosed little by little by
agreement,
and then they rounded the whole
thing off by dividing up and
portioning out the woodlands and
common pasture of the manor.
The whole idea of this was to
create consolidated farms which
would be under the individual
management of a particular
farmer.
That gave those farmers freedom
of movement in managing and
adapting their husbandry
practice as they saw fit.
Intensification of methods was
not impossible in the old open
fields,
but it was much easier on farms
under individual management,
and in consequence the old
communally managed customary
system of agriculture gradually
weakened.
It weakened its hold on
agricultural organization
generally,
survived in some areas,
but in many parts of the
country it was gradually
disappearing and in some it was
almost wholly extinguished.
Right.
Overall, various combinations
of changes of this kind appear
to have boosted agricultural
output considerably,
even boosting the yields per
acre, the productivity of the
land.
The study which is represented
by the figures on two--
table 2(b)--on your handout of
land productivity in a number of
counties,
a study based upon farmers'
inventories--
the crops that are recorded in
their inventories and also on
some surviving account books--
this suggests that in these
counties cereal yields,
numbers of bushels per acre,
rose by about 15% in the late
sixteenth century and by another
4% in the early seventeenth
century.
Okay.
Well, gradual change of this
kind in agriculture implies that
there existed a larger market
for agricultural produce and in
some ways a more distant market
for agricultural produce that
farmers were trying to serve.
And those markets were found,
as you would imagine,
above all in the towns and in
those areas of the countryside
which had large populations
which were engaged in activities
other than agriculture;
industrial areas of the
countryside.
This was a period of very
marked urbanization,
very significant urban growth.
Some of the figures are there
on table three on your handout
for a number of cities.
In Worcester,
for example,
the population rose between
1550 and 1650 from just over
4,000 to roughly 8,000.
In Norwich the population of
the city rose from about 10,000
to over 30,000.
And above all there was massive
population growth in the city of
London.
The figures are there for you.
In 1550, London was already
about 70,000,
by 1600 200,000,
by 1650 400,000 and still
growing.
By 1600, London already
contained 5% of the national
population.
By 1650, London contained just
over 9% of the national
population and was still
growing, and today it's about
10%.
It had almost reached that
proportion in the
mid-seventeenth century.
So very significant urban
growth.
All of that involved,
within particular cities,
the taking up of vacant space
within their walls for building,
the subdivision of existing
housing and the growth of
suburbs outside the old city
walls.
In London, for example,
by the 1580s there were
complaints by the local
authorities of what they called
"pestering of houses with
diverse families"
or multiple occupation.
Or again "multitudes of
people"--
these are
quotations--"multitudes of
people brought to inhabit in
small rooms and...
heaped up together and in a
sort almost smothered,"
said one report.
Overcrowding;
congestion.
In addition,
in the parishes outside the
city walls there was significant
suburban growth.
The parishes of east London,
to the east of the Tower of
London, the modern East End,
in the 1570s contained about
7,000 people already.
So there was already a
significant population in these
parishes just outside the old
city walls.
By the 1630s,
there were 50,000 people in the
east London suburbs.
Or if we turn to western London
the parish of St.
Martin-in-the-Fields,
which was literally in the
fields in the mid-sixteenth
century, had a population of
about 600 when Elizabeth came to
the throne.
By the 1630s,
St.
Martin's had a population of
18,000.
So this single London suburban
parish contained more people
than most of the cities in other
parts of the kingdom.
The Church of St.
Martin-in-the-Fields is the one
that stands beside Trafalgar
Square today right in the heart
of the city.
Well, this formidable urban
growth occurred despite alarming
levels of urban mortality in the
overcrowded, increasingly
insanitary towns.
They didn't have adequate water
supply.
They didn't have adequate
sanitation measures.
'Background mortality',
ordinary, everyday mortality
from infectious disease in the
towns was very bad,
far worse than in the
countryside.
Even within the cities it could
vary quite significantly.
For example,
in the late sixteenth century
average life expectation at
birth in the wealthier districts
of London was thirty to
thirty-five.
Average life expectation of
birth in the poorer parishes of
the East End was only twenty to
twenty-five.
The towns were also prone,
of course, to catastrophic
'crisis morality' in the form of
epidemics, particularly
epidemics of bubonic plague.
Norwich saw five major
epidemics of bubonic plague
between 1579 and 1640.
London also saw five in the
same period and most other major
cities witnessed a number.
These outbreaks could kill
10-15% of the population or even
worse.
In York in 1604,
which was a really bad year,
when the plague spread from
city to city across the
kingdom--
in York in that year roughly
30% of the population died.
In Newcastle up here in the
northeast in 1636 an estimated
47% of the population died
between May and October of that
year.
These were absolutely
devastating events and they were
at their worst in the poorer,
overcrowded,
dirtier areas of the cities.
It's been said by Paul Slack,
who's written a wonderful book
about the impact of the plague,
that there was a "distinct
urban topography"
of the plague.
The disease was no respecter of
persons, but it raged at its
worst under certain social
conditions.
And yet despite these appalling
catastrophes the towns continued
to grow, London above all.
One of the earliest
demographers,
a man named John Graunt who
published a study based upon the
mortality figures for London
which were regularly collected
by the city authorities to keep
an eye on the epidemic disease
situation.
He studied them for the first
time.
He made various projections on
the basis of those figures.
He was a great pioneer of the
use of statistical information.
He came to the conclusion--I'm
quoting him--
"let the mortality be what
it will,
this city repairs itself within
two years."
The loss of inhabitants could
be rapidly replaced.
And the evidence is that this
was so, and of course the loss
was replaced primarily by
continued migration to the
towns.
It's been calculated that in
order to replace the numbers who
died under these dreadful
mortality conditions and to
continue to grow in the way that
it did London needed an average
of 6,000 new people a year
coming in to the city to replace
its losses and grow.
And the evidence is that they
came.
Some of them came as what one
demographer describes as
"betterment migrants,"
people who came to the city in
fairly confident expectation of
better opportunities.
They might come in as
apprentices to be apprenticed to
a particular trade,
their apprenticeship having
been arranged by members of
their family.
They might be people who came
in with a known place to fill.
Very often for example they
might have relatives already in
the city who would encourage
their migration to join them.
A very interesting study by
Vivien Brodsky of single women
marrying for the first time in
London and taking out licenses
to marry,
which give us some details of
their circumstances,
she finds, interestingly,
that two fifths of these single
women marrying in London had kin
in the city with whom they were
living at the time that they
married.
So they'd come in from the
countryside,
they were living with family
members already in the city,
and then they established
themselves and married there.
Other people came not as
betterment migrants with good
prospects of that kind but as
what have been described as
"subsistence
migrants,"
people looking for any
opportunity to find work and
hoping that the city would
provide it.
And clearly it did,
perhaps not the opportunities
that people hoped for--
the streets of London were
certainly not paved with gold--
but opportunities of a kind,
to make a living of some kind.
The quickening urban economies
of other cities also did the
same.
In Colchester and in Norwich,
for example,
the cloth industry was
expanding, particularly with the
help of refugees from the
Netherlands,
from the religious wars of the
who came and were placed in
those cities by Elizabeth's
government and who were welcomed
because they introduced certain
advanced cloth-making
techniques,
which helped to improve the
local cloth industry and assist
its expansion.
In London above all you get a
spectacular diversification of
manufacturing activity.
In east London along the river
there were shipyards.
There were also businesses
producing all sorts of other
goods ancillary to the shipping
industry: rope making,
sail making,
coopers making barrels,
people making pulleys,
pulley makers for the ropes
that held--
for the rigging of the ships.
In London you also find
textiles, especially luxury
textiles,
a massive brewing industry,
metal trades,
sugar refining,
starch making,
soap making,
glass making,
and so one could go.
And then of course there was
all the activity around the
wharves and the river in what
was England's greatest trading
city.
So urban economies were
expanding.
The numbers of apprentices
being taken on were growing,
the level of activity was
growing, the activities
themselves were proliferating.
But manufacturing in other
industries also extended well
beyond the cities.
Manufacturing of some products
had long been established in
rural villages under the
'putting out' system,
and this period also witnessed
considerable growth in
activities of this kind.
It rarely involved really
significant technological change
of the kind that we associate
with the industrial revolution
and the birth of the factory
system,
but what it often saw was the
adoption,
or the imitation,
of the best practices known at
the time and the diversification
of the products which were being
produced,
and there was also something of
a spread in the geographical
location of various kinds of
manufacturing activity.
As you know,
the premier traditional
industry was the production of
woolen broadcloth,
most of it exported to the
Netherlands where traditionally
it was finished and then passed
on to markets across Europe.
This traditional industry had
had something of a crisis of
overproduction in the 1550s and
thereafter found that its
markets were somewhat declining.
Its overseas markets were
somewhat declining and it faced
pretty stiff competition from
the Dutch.
But the textile industries
continued to expand nonetheless.
The most dynamic areas of
textiles were not the old
broadcloth industry but the
production of what they called
the "new draperies."
The new draperies.
These were lighter,
fully finished,
more colorful cloths rather
like modern suit cloth.
If old--if the old broadcloths
were rather like a heavy
blanket,
then if you imagine modern
suiting cloths that's what the
new draperies were like,
worsteds of various kinds.
They had lovely names for them.
They were always inventing
fancy names for these new
cloths: Bays and Says and
Perpetuanas and Calimancoes.
All of these were different
forms of worsted cloth.
The new draperies were centered
in the towns of East Anglia
where they had been- where their
establishment had been greatly
assisted by the influx of
skilled refugees from the
Netherlands.
They brought their expertise
and they helped to revive and
transform the cloth industries
of those areas especially around
Norwich and Colchester.
But the new draperies were not
the whole story of textile
diversification.
Up in Lancashire around the
town of Manchester,
which at this time was not a
great city but a small market
town,
there was the growth in the
late sixteenth and early
seventeenth centuries of the
manufacture of so-called
"fustians."
Fustians involved a mixture of
cotton and linen and the
production of this cloth--
it was cheap,
coarse cloth for the home
market,
cloth for the poor--was
centered around Manchester.
It's the distant ancestor of
what was later to be the great
cotton industry of the city of
Manchester.
Another thing that was
spreading in many rural areas
was stocking knitting.
The wives of farmers and
agricultural laborers were often
involved in knitting
high-quality stockings.
Many people knitted stockings
for themselves,
but there was a market for
high-quality stockings supplied
by people working in that way.
The stocking industry spread
all over Norfolk,
spread across the Midlands into
the Nottinghamshire area,
which is actually still to this
day a center for the manufacture
of stockings and underwear.
Marks and Spencer's gets a lot
of stuff from Nottinghamshire
and so on.
One could talk about silks,
luxury textiles.
Silks were introduced by French
Protestant refugees from
southern France and silk
production became established
principally in eastern London
and also in the town of
Canterbury in Kent.
So, a lot of diversification,
not only in woolen textiles but
in some new developments like
silk.
And this was part of a larger
diversification of manufacturing
in town and country.
A lot of the new--the
altogether new manufacturers
which were introduced were
really forms of import
substitution encouraged by the
royal government so that things
could be produced at home rather
than imported.
Traditionally,
a great deal of miscellaneous
manufactured goods actually were
imported, principally from the
Netherlands or north Germany.
Under Elizabeth the privy
council was very responsive
indeed to anyone with good ideas
for introducing these things
into England.
They would often encourage them
by granting them a patent which
would give them the monopoly of
producing a certain item for a
stated period of years,
after which it would be open to
anyone who wished to participate
in the industry once it was
established.
It's the origins of the patent
system, of course.
Well, numerous patents were
granted.
To take some examples,
which may seem almost silly but
they mattered.
Pins.
One doesn't usually think of
pins when one thinks of major
economic expansion,
but in 1597 England imported
40,000 pounds' worth of pins
from the Netherlands.
That's a lot of pins,
and a lot of money.
In the first decade of the
seventeenth century,
pin manufacturing was
established under patent in the
suburbs of London.
They mostly employed children
making the pins.
By the 1630s,
the patent had expired and it
spread beyond London,
became particularly established
in villages in the west of
England in the Gloucestershire
area.
From about this time onward,
most English pins were produced
at home, and so one could go on.
Glass was nearly always
imported before the 1580s.
Patents were then granted for
introducing glass manufacture
particular--
particularly to the counties of
Kent and Sussex and then it
spread to some other places.
There were glassworks around
Newcastle very soon.
By the 1620s,
nearly all glass bottles used
in England were being produced
at home instead of imported,
and so on.
Well, industries of this kind
were generally somewhat
decentralized in their
organization.
They were organized on the
putting out system.
They didn't involve a great
deal in the way of investment in
fixed capital in the form of
industrial plant,
machinery and so forth.
Principally,
they needed the capital to buy
raw materials,
to pay workers who were working
in their own cottages or
workshops;
to market the finished goods.
It was all done on the putting
out system,
but there were a number of
other industries which were also
beginning to bring a rather
different face to industrial
activity.
Iron for example.
Iron manufacturing really got
going in the mid-sixteenth
century when the technique of
using blast furnaces was
introduced into England from
Germany.
It was greatly encouraged by
Elizabeth's privy council
because they wanted iron
production domestically for the
production of munitions.
By the 1570s,
there were over fifty blast
furnaces operating in the
forests of the area known as the
Weald,
down here towards the south
coast, the forested area with
fast-running streams which were
suitable for driving some of the
machinery involved.
In the early seventeenth
century, the industry in the
Weald had stabilized,
even declined a little,
but there was a great deal of
relocation to south Wales,
largely because that area
offered a combination of iron
ore,
forests to provide the timber
to produce charcoal for the
blast furnaces,
and also fast-running streams
to drive the machinery which was
used in slitting mills in iron
production,
machinery driven by water
wheels.
All of this is very interesting
to go into in detail to see the
technology they used,
but I'll spare you that,
but it can be followed up if
these things interest you.
By...by the 1580s,
the levels of iron production
of the 1550s had increased
threefold.
By the 1640s,
England was producing 23-24,000
tons of pig iron a year.
Those were the signs of things
to come in the iron industry
which continued to grow,
but a lot of iron was still
imported from Scandinavia in
particular,
from Sweden especially,
to serve a growing industry
producing metal wares and that
was centered in the West
Midlands around the town of
Birmingham.
Metalware production had taken
place there for many years,
indeed centuries,
but was greatly increasing.
They produced there many metal
products used in agriculture and
in the building industries and
in shipping;
nails and locks and scythes and
buckles, latches for doors,
bits and stirrups for horses,
and so forth.
All of this was organized by
iron masters who lived in
emerging towns like Birmingham,
Walsall, and Stourbridge,
and they did it partly by
employing independent master
craftsmen to produce specialized
goods for them and also by
putting out work--
putting out raw materials for
the simpler items like nail
making,
to cottagers who worked part
time.
And so one can go on.
Lead production was also
expanding.
Some of the figures are there
in table four,
1560s only about 600 tons of
lead produced per annum,
by the 1630s well over 12,000.
Lead production was centered in
the hills of Derbyshire and in
parts of Somerset where lead
deposits were to be found.
And finally,
perhaps most spectacular of all
in the introduction of these new
heavier industries,
was the growth of the coal
industry.
The coal industry,
centered around Newcastle on
the River Tyne,
grew spectacularly under
Elizabeth and the early Stuarts
in response above all to the
demands for fuel exerted by
London and other growing cities.
In the 1580s,
Newcastle exported to London
through the coastal trade 50,000
tons of coal a year.
By the 1640s,
it was exporting 300,000 tons
of coal per year in addition to
which by 1640 another 200,000
tons were being exported to
other English cities.
The coal industry could not
have grown as it did without the
demand being exerted by these
growing urban centers.
Those urban centers could not
have grown as they did without
the fuel, the cheap fuel which
was coming from the mines of the
North.
By 1650, the Northeast
alone--and there were coal
fields in some other areas too--
but the Northeast alone was
producing half a million tons of
coal per annum,
quite extraordinary output.
Just to give you a sense of
what that might mean,
a recent historian of these
developments has calculated that
a ton of coal yields roughly the
same heat energy as the charcoal
which could be produced by
harvesting timber on an acre of
land.
Okay?
So same heat energy as the
timber from an acre of land.
So, if you're producing half a
million tons of coal per annum
you have in effect created half
a million acres of land,
as it were, in terms of
your--the capacity you would
need in order to produce that
amount of heat energy,
and that heat energy was used
not only for domestic heating
but for any industrial process
which required heat.
They couldn't use it for
smelting iron yet but they could
use it for many,
many industrial processes.
Is that all clear?
Good. You get the point.
It's an interesting way of
representing the difference that
that kind of industrial
development could make.
Okay.
Well, much of this built on
existing foundations,
but the sheer scale of
expansion began to give a very
distinct regional geography to
the English economy.
There were distinctive areas of
agricultural specialization
emerging and there were also
those areas which were rendered
distinctive by their involvement
in industrial activity.
One traveler traveling through
the West Midlands near
Birmingham in the 1640s
described it as being like
"one continued
village,"
large village after large
village heavily involved in iron
production.
The Stour Valley area
stretching up from Colchester
where the new draperies were
well established was described
as with--
continuing--consisting of a
constellation of villages in
which a small number of
clothiers set on work "a
great company of poor
people."
There again there's the
extraordinary moonscape which
was emerging around the
Newcastle coal field area in
which there were many,
many individual pits working
down to depths of two or three
hundred feet.
And then they couldn't really
go any deeper because of
drainage problems so they would
simply open a new pit,
creating a kind of moonscape
across that whole area.
This kind of regional
differentiation enhanced the
redistribution of the population
as people seeking work moved to
places which had the capacity to
provide them with some kind of
employment,
be it in agriculture of
particular kinds or in industry.
I've already touched on the
migration to the towns.
There was also migration to
certain rural areas which were
becoming very densely populated,
especially the manufacturing
districts,
and those densely populated
areas of course exerted demand
in their turn for the
agricultural products of a more
specialized agriculture.
Something of the redistribution
of population which was going on
is summarized in section five of
your handout.
There are some figures
calculated by the demographer
E.A. Wrigley showing that
between 1520 and 1670 the rural
agricultural population,
those directly employed in
agriculture,
was significantly reduced,
the urban population living in
towns of over 5,000 rose from
about 5.5% to over 13%,
and the rural non-agricultural
population rose from about 18%
to something like 26%.
That's the people living in
small towns all working in rural
industry.
All of this was of course
linked together by internal
trade.
The established arteries of
internal trade grew in their
significance.
Road traffic increased.
Traffic around the coast and on
the rivers, a very good way of
moving bulky goods,
greatly increased.
Networks of internal trade were
elaborated and tightened.
If that had not happened,
then none of these developments
would have been possible.
The emerging picture is one of
an elaborating web of commercial
interconnection pulling the
various regional economies
together even more tightly than
had previously been the case.
And this intensification of
commercial activity involved new
commercial practices,
and one of the best indicators
of the sheer extent of what was
going on is actually provided by
the evidence of the law courts.
A great deal of the litigation
which took place in England's
law courts concerned broken
contracts,
disagreements over debts or the
meeting of contractual
obligations.
There was an absolutely massive
rise in the amount of such
business within the courts.
If you look at section six of
your handout,
you'll see that in 1560 just
over 5,000 cases of this kind
were heard by the central courts
in London.
By 1640, it was almost 29,000
cases being heard a year.
And this is just the tip of the
iceberg.
These are the deals that went
wrong and resulted in someone
suing someone else.
One can only imagine the
massive amount of commercial
activity which was going on.
Whereas in 1500,
then, a great deal of the
marketing which had taken place
in England was rather localized,
with some longer distance flows
going across the kingdom in
particular commodities--
cattle, cloth and so forth--by
the early seventeenth century
one gets a picture of a society
which was ever more closely
interconnected and integrated by
market dealings and commercial
transactions.
This was in short a
commercializing society,
an emerging market economy in
which the living and the daily
economic dealings of a far
larger proportion of the
population were shaped by the
market.
And finally it wasn't just
becoming a more internally
integrated commercial society,
it was one which was also
linked increasingly to a larger
world.
Because the same decades in the
late sixteenth and early
seventeenth centuries saw a
transformation of overseas
trade,
from a pattern which had been
very much based on
short-distance traffic across
the English Channel,
a few voyages down to other
French and perhaps Spanish
ports,
but predominantly concentrated
on the narrow seas,
to one in which English
merchants were trading directly
with far more diverse areas of
the world.
They began doing so partly to
look for new markets for English
cloth,
partly also to get direct
access to the source of much
desired imports which had
previously been obtained from
the Netherlands.
They stopped trying to go
direct to source;
looking for grain,
for wine, for spices,
for luxury textiles from far
afield.
The late sixteenth century,
of course,
was the beginning of the great
age of exploratory voyages by
English navigators,
the voyages of Francis Drake,
Martin Frobisher and so forth.
But the really significant
thing from the point of view of
the economic development of the
period were those who
undertake--
undertook trading voyages to
establish new trades,
often with royal backing,
often through forming companies
which would get a royal charter
to conduct trade with somewhere
with which England had not
previously traded direct.
So companies were founded with
royal charters to trade to the
Baltic in search of the furs,
the grain of Poland,
the timber products of
Scandinavia,
all of which had a place in
England's growing economy.
Companies were founded to trade
with Russia, sailing north
around Scandinavia to the port
of Archangel.
They intended to proceed from
there to get access to central
Asian goods,
though that was an enterprise
which didn't succeed,
but they established trade with
Muscovy.
There was increasing trade
direct with Spain principally
for wine and currants,
which were extremely popular.
There was direct trade with
Italy first of all and then with
the Levant, bringing in spices,
luxury textiles,
wine and other goods.
And finally,
once the Muscovy company had
learned that it could not
successfully reach the East via
Russia,
they imitated the Portuguese
and went the other way,
around Africa to establish the
trade with the East Indies with
the voyages of the East India
Company chartered in 1599 and
voyaging for the first time in
1601.
All of these trades once they
had become established were
consolidated and expanding in
the course of the early
seventeenth century when they
were joined by yet another area
of activity,
the Atlantic trades.
By the 1630s,
there were already 300 English
ships a year fishing off
Newfoundland and bringing back
the fish to Europe where dried
cod was particularly popular in
parts of southern Europe.
And increasingly trade had been
established with the colonies
established upon the American
mainland,
after 1607, in Virginia and
then Maryland of course,
from the 1620s onwards in the
Northeast,
and Caribbean colonies,
notably Barbados,
being established in the same
period.
Jamaica wasn't conquered until
the 1650s.
Most of these colonies managed
to get on their feet through
establishing plantation
economies of course,
and they produced the goods
which were increasingly imported
into England and then sold on to
other customers.
Tobacco for example,
tobacco first being produced in
large quantities from 1617 in
Virginia, the salvation of the
colony.
60,000 thousand pounds of
tobacco were being imported into
London already by 1622.
By 1638, they were bringing in
two million pounds of tobacco
per annum, and from-- yes,
we're very ungrateful to
tobacco,
>
it had a major role.
And that was followed from the
1640s by another product about
which we're very ungrateful,
sugar, being produced in the
West Indies and exported for
refining in London.
So then we have a panorama of
economic expansion.
Attempts to establish overall
national income in this period
are extremely dodgy,
but a number of heroic economic
historians have attempted to do
it and you'll find the estimates
there in section eight of your
table.
It seems likely that between
the 1560s and the 1590s national
income had risen by about 48%
and it rose by a further 51%
between the 1590s and 1640,
over the 80 years as a whole
something like 120% growth in
national income in real terms.
If they're right about that,
and even if they're wrong by
20%, it's still a lot.
If they're right about that,
it helps to account for the
fact that population growth was
sustained as long as it was and
for the growing signs of
prosperity which one finds
throughout this period.
And yet despite those positive
and optimistic signs,
as you'll see in the final
table, table nine,
the prices of basic foodstuffs
were still rising,
suggesting that despite
increased output there was a
continued imbalance between
population and food resources.
The period also saw complaints
of poverty and a continuing
decline in the purchasing power
of wages,
the declining real wages which
you'll find in the final column
of that table on the right.
So having looked at the
panorama of economic expansion,
what we have to do next time is
to look at how this growing
national wealth was actually
distributed socially and how the
trends of this period worked out
in terms of the actual life
chances of particular social
groups.
And I'll do that on Thursday.